they raised the sighting device removed the
ring they started the
flamethrower they put in particular well
-proven rocket-propelled flamethrowers
they are used in the assault of
long-term firing points
of settlements the material is absorbed
very easily the
practice is available, that is, there are no problems
created by the instructor, the
territorial defense forces of Ukraine actively
use that is, these
are the same mobilized military personnel
they actively use Bander smoothies before
they were called Molotov cocktails But
now they are in their own way And they changed the
mood among the guys to a fighting one,
as if everyone understands
that the Motherland asked for help
and we fulfilled the
Neva Veliky number continues to burn